welcome back to cbs this morning
president trump has signed a nearly 900
billion dollar coveted relief package
that he called
a disgrace mr trump is still pushing
congress to remove what he calls
wasteful items and increased the size of
payments to americans despite objections
from his
own party meanwhile the president still
has not conceded the november election
insisting
he lost because of his unproven claims
of voter fraud
cbs news senior political analyst and 60
minutes correspondent john dickerson
joins us now john good morning good to
see you
good morning vlad good to see you so
president trump abruptly reverse course
he signed this covett relief bill
after his initial resistance and largely
being absent from the negotiations why
well it's it's not certain i mean let's
take it at face value the president's
strategy
seemed to have been that in this crisis
moment he wanted to
basically use the deadline and the high
stakes the fact that people
were uh in danger of losing benefits
that people were really hurting use that
to get more
in terms of benefits and also to cut
spending that's what he said out loud
the problem is he had no leverage uh and
so when he tried to use the crisis of
the deadline to get leverage to get more
uh it didn't work at all of course
there's been plenty of
reporting that suggests also that he was
throwing a kind of tantrum
angry at republican leaders for not
buying his notion about a stolen
election
uh and that he was basically just
causing chaos
uh but not either way uh it didn't get
him anything
yeah it's not clear what his strategy
was uh the president waited until the
bill was on his desk before weighing in
with criticism of his own party's
demands and i'm just trying to
understand
the strategy what are you hearing
well i mean you're right so this people
should remember this was patiently
worked out by his own administration by
his treasury secretary
uh and and the problem with uh
government is that it is sometimes
imperfect and sometimes you can only
get half a low for three quarters of a
loaf uh it was all worked out to the
best deal they could get
given the situation and given the
approaching deadline
so by coming in at the last minute um he
tried to use that as leverage but
there was no leverage to be had and it
was
highly ineffective and it wasted a lot
of time and
it's not like the stakes aren't high for
all the other things on the agenda
in front of government there is a lot to
be concerned about
and so this was really just a lot of
wasted effort running around the
mulberry bush
as you know john the president also
demanded that wasteful items be removed
from the omnibus bills which keeps the
government funded
um i saw you musing about this on
twitter it struck me that the president
was like a big city editor
looking at the bill and redlining it but
does he have the ability to even do that
well the important thing to know when
looking at this entire drama is it's not
that the goals the president had were
somehow
unworthy it was the process by which he
went about trying to achieve those goals
that was highly ineffective uh
and so what ended up happening in the
end is he signed a bill
the bill didn't change in the way he
wanted it to and he got none of the
things he asked for
what he said is he'll be redlining the
bill using
something called the impoundment control
act of 1974
as all americans know uh and this is a
real thing
it has been used not since the year 2000
but it's used in
highly specific situations um and
basically if you read the letter of that
impounded control act
there's no way congress is going to do
what he's asking it to do
so in a sense even though what he says
is not completely made up
uh it essentially has no effectiveness
and will do nothing to change the
spending so it's kind of a pretend thing
john let me ask you about the senate
runoffs in georgia could the president's
claims of election fraud
his resistance to this bill could that
potentially affect voter turnout in
georgia
you know it's always difficult to try to
predict what voter turnout is going to
look like i said we learned that
in this last election and we should have
had to learn it again because it's
always dangerous
i think what we've seen is there's been
a great deal of money that's been
donated
more money to the democrats than the
republicans of course that was true in
many races this last cycle
and the republicans went ahead and won
there has been confusion
people acting on the president's behalf
who say the election is stolen telling
republicans in georgia not to vote
for the two senate candidates but the
president's now going there for a rally
so you don't want confusion in elections
you want people to be riled up and on
your side and one of the strongest
arguments republicans have
is that they need to be a check in the
senate against a democratic president
joe biden
the problem is that the president is
saying that he doesn't believe joe biden
is president so
there is a contradiction whether it has
political power and causes people not to
vote
we're just going to have to wait to see
john dickerson
making us smarter this morning
appreciate it as always john thank you
very much